all right so Mother Nature's kind of
whipping up just a few High thin clouds
out there this morning it's certainly
not holding back the temperatures though
from dropping into freezing territory
for Nellis in the Northeast Sunrise
Mountain very close 33 and Seven Hills
34 at Mountain's Edge look at all these
30s it's cold out there take a nice warm
jacket and coat kiddos have two days of
school and then they're off Wednesday
you're off Wednesday through the weekend
you have a nice long holiday but you've
got to get through the first part of the
week 20s in Indian Springs Pahrump
freezing in Sandy Valley look at the
teens Caliente over to Cedar City up to
Ely and even Reno in the upper teens oh
my goodness it is cold around Nevada so
we'll be looking for light winds
Sunshine below normal temps to start off
the wheat but by Thanksgiving we'll be
warming up to the upper 60s that will be
the warmest day of the week on Thursday
and then staying mostly sunny and dry
into the weekend
there is another cold front kind of
headed for the coast but that's pretty
much going to stay and actually affect
the upper or the I should say the
Northwest down south will stay dry but
it is bringing in just a few high clouds
ahead of it we'll get more of those
tonight into tomorrow around the Great
Lakes oh it is still oh so cold and they
are buried on that epic snowstorm from
over the weekend so you know the Buffalo
Bills game had to be moved to Detroit
because this is what it looked like at
Orchard Park oh my gosh that was
Highmark stadium covered in 80 inches of
snow I think the snow was all the way up
to the first row of seats in the stadium
it was actually it was absolutely crazy
and epic over the weekend it was the
third highest record-setting snowstorm
and snowfall in New York for a three-day
period so I can't even believe it didn't
Eclipse all the other records all right
dry conditions by the way I think the
Bills beat Cleveland 31-28 something
like that dry and we'll look for more
Sunshine as we get through the day did
these high clouds will slip through then
we'll get more clouds tonight into
Tuesday still mostly sunny tomorrow see
the warm-up 68 by Thursday staying a
little above normal into the weekend go
figure but still nice for all that
shopping that everybody's going to be
doing 6 49
[Music]